[Music]
perfumers can learn to distinguish
individual odors in a fragrance made of
hundreds of scents tea experts have been
known to sniff out not just the location
where a tea was from but the season of
harvest and whether it was planted by a
plum tree and the New York City Transit
Authority once had an employee
responsible only for sniffing out gas
leaks in the subway system can just
anyone learn to smell with the
sensitivity of those experts for most of
us what we smell is largely involuntary
whether it's garbage behind a restaurant
the shampoo of the woman leaving an
elevator as you enter or a bakeries
fresh made bread with a few million
olfactory receptors in our noses we
clearly don't lack the ability to smell
well we just might not always pay close
enough attention that's a shame because
we may be missing opportunities to make
strong emotional connections smells are
powerfully linked to emotions and can
awaken memories of places we've long ago
left and people we've loved but
fortunately it is possible to train our
brains to smell better
for example Helen Keller was able to
recognize a person's work and in her
words distinguish the carpenter from the
iron worker the artist from the mason or
the chemist by a simple inhale follow
these steps and you too can change the
way the world smells to you first
stick your nose in it some animals that
are known to be great smeller's like
dogs who can sniff out explosives and
pigs who can find truffles underground
put their noses right at the place they
want to smell human noses meanwhile are
casting around in the middle of the air
giving us an anatomical disadvantage so
bring your nose close to the world
around you the ground surfaces objects
the food in your hand get close to your
dog your partner the book you're reading
not only will your nose be closer to the
odor source but the warmth of your
breath will make odors easier to smell
second sniff like you mean it
smelling actually happens way up near
the bridge of our noses in a postage
stamp-sized square
of tissue called the olfactory
epithelium when we sniff odor molecules
are sucked up into our nostrils until
they hit this tissue where they can bind
to our olfactory or scent receptors when
we inhale normally only a little air
makes it there but one or two solid
sharp snips will ensure that more air
gets to your smell receptors after just
a few more sniffs the receptors which
are best at noticing new smells turn off
temporarily so you can give your nose a
rest and sniff again later
finally dwell on the smell most smells
pass by us with little attention but
simply noticing what you're smelling and
trying to describe it name it and locate
its source you can expand your own
vocabulary of smells when an odor
molecule binds to a scent receptor it
sends an electrical signal from the
sensory neurons to our brains or factory
bulbs the signal then continues to other
areas of the brain where it's integrated
with taste memory or emotional
information before registering to us as
a smell fMRI research shows that the
extra time spent focusing on scent
changes the brain of experienced
smeller's for them perceiving and
imagining odors becomes more automatic
than for norm experts to get started
yourself take ingredients from your
kitchen spices vanilla or fruit but
never anything toxic close your eyes and
have someone bring them under your nose
sniff and try to name the source over
time you'll begin to appreciate nuances
in familiar odors and recognize
characteristics of new and unusual
smells the perfumer has practiced these
steps enough to become an artist of odor
but even if you never pursue smelling to
that degree the spectacular result of an
unspectacular action will change how you
sense and experience your days
Oh
[Music]